I think you should be doing things for
yourself and your family out of the
process not the stuff attention is the
number one asset when entrepreneurs post
that stuff I don't think that's
aspirational I really don't if you look
carefully it's making a lot of people in
this audience and in the world feel bad
about themselves they see all these
people they fomo it triggers their
insecurity and so as such a capitalist I
do worry about the over capitalization
of the content but that's always been
the case long before social media people
bought Mercedes and Chanel bags and
moved to
90210 just for the validation there are
people in the world who send their kids
to certain schools for their own
selfworth I worry about that I don't
like that I think you should be doing
things for yourself and your family out
of the process not the stuff because I
think you'll be happier mentally and you
won't burn out and I think that's
important